NARRATOR: On the shore
of Lake Michigan located
just a few miles
south of Muskegon,
Kevin Dykstra believes he
has located physical evidence
of an abandoned Confederate
train engine buried some four
feet beneath the sand.
If he can dig an area
deep enough and wide
enough so that it
can be photographed,
Kevin is hoping it will serve
as proof that will convince
fellow treasure hunter and
Michigan businessman Marty
Lagina to finance what
promises to be a very
expensive search to
find a boxcar filled
with lost Confederate gold.
After the Civil
War ended in 1865,
a company called the
Florida Rail Road reported
that a Confederate
locomotive had been stolen
in the city of Cedar Keys.
KEVIN DYKSTRA: Who can steal
something from a railroad?
Who can steal a train engine?
I believe that it
was Colonel Minty.
NARRATOR: Colonel
Robert H.G. Minty
was one of the Union officers
responsible for the arrest
of Jefferson Davis.
According to Kevin
Dykstra's research,
it was Minty who tipped off
Lieutenant Colonel Benjamin
Pritchard to the fact that
the Confederate president was
fleeing south with the
Confederate treasury and
to capture Davis at all costs.
After the war, Minty
became the superintendent
of a number of
railroad companies,
overseeing expansion projects
and general management.
One of those companies
was the Florida Rail Road,
which he joined around 1869,
one year before Kevin Dykstra
believes Minty arranged
for the gold that
was secretly buried
in Georgia to be
brought to Michigan by rail.
Kevin Dykstra must now
face a sobering reality.
Even if a stolen Confederate
locomotive really
does lie buried
beneath the sand,
it may be too close to the water
to be successfully exposed.
I don't believe
there's anything more
physically that we could do.
We brought in 20 people.
The sand just keeps
washing back in.
NARRATOR: Refusing
to give up on what
could be a historic
discovery, Kevin and his team
now shift their focus to
uncover what they believe to be
the abandoned railroad tracks.
We're just under eight feet.
That should have hit it
if you were going to hit it.
NARRATOR: Eight feet down and
still no sign of the tracks?
KEVIN DYKSTRA: I know
the tracks are there.
I have to get down to that
railroad track for two reasons.
One, because I will
not let it beat me.
I will find that.
I will get right to it.
And the other is I want
to show it to Marty.
Got something right there.
Sweet.
I heard it.
That's got to be
the railroad track.
NARRATOR: In an
attempt to create
a reinforced digging
shaft, the team
now uses a three-foot-wide
steel caisson.
If they can pump water
out of the metal cylinder,
they hope to confirm that the
object buried beneath the sand
is an abandoned train track.
We got a ticking clock.
I've got to get that sleeve
down about 2 and 1/2 feet.
We're going to start extricating
all of that sand and mud.
That sleeve is going to go down.
Will we get to that
railroad track?
I believe we will.
Can you take that probe
down and push down?
All right.
It's right there.
I think we can get to it.
We just keep digging
and digging and digging.
You probably should back up.
[all exclaim]
NARRATOR: Suddenly, after what
seems like the perfect plan
to get deep enough to find
the suspected railroad tracks,
the hole once again caves
in due to incoming water.
You're losing the other bank.
Big time.
NARRATOR: But Kevin Dykstra
is not ready to give up.
KEVIN DYKSTRA: All right.
Start the generator
up, and let's try
to get some water out of there.
Man, we're so close.
[whirring]
NARRATOR: Although
Kevin's brother Al
can feel one of the metal tracks
buried deep below the sand,
the influx of water is making
it impossible for the team
to expose it.
KEVIN DYKSTRA: How can I get
down to that railroad track?
I mean, we put our hands on it.
So I figured it out.
We came out with a
38-inch tube to go
over top of the 36-inch tube.
But it's much taller, so I can
stack one on top of the other
and get right down to
that railroad track.
NARRATOR: For Kevin
Dykstra and his team,
it has been a day of both
extreme highs and bitter lows.
Although he is convinced he
has successfully located both
the stolen locomotive
and the abandoned
railroad tracks,
he cannot dig them
up sufficiently to prove it.
I don't know what to do.
As much as I want
to move forward from
this point right here, I can't.
NARRATOR: If he is to secure
the necessary financing he needs
from Marty Lagina and undertake
a search for the gold that may
still lie at the bottom
of Lake Michigan,
he will need a new strategy.